hey what's up on today's show we talked
to a young man who did a dna test and
found out that the guy he thought was
his dad
isn't we talked to a young mom whose
daughter has add and she wants some
practical tips
on how she can help support her daughter
and we talk to an exhausted
yet heroic nurse who's been in
california working with patients with
covid
for month after month and she's just
exhausted
what can she do to get her life back
stay tuned
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show
i'm glad you're here glad you're walking
with us
on this show we talk about mental health
relationships what's going on in your
life
and your marriage and your home with
that boyfriend with that girlfriend
with your kids when you find that thing
out about your sister you didn't know or
your brother
your grandparents all of it man we talk
about everything on this show
it's about you right the good stuff the
rough stuff the bad
stuff what can we can what we can do
next
you know and i i learned early on
um i can't fake it on this show
so if i'm having an awesome day i come
across a little bit fired up if i'm
having a rough day a hard day
um yeah i just want to be honest about
it it's tough
and sometimes i will stumble across
something or read something
and um it just weighs heavy on me and so
we're going to talk about that here
whatever's going on your life give me a
call 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or if you are the typing type
that pretty much sounded like i was a
rapper if you're the typing type
go ahead and type uh www.johndaloney.com
show and i've heard recently that you
don't need the www
anymore so hashtag old guy i don't even
know if hashtags are cool i'm going to
start raising the roof here in a minute
but go to john delany.com
show and um fill out the form and it
goes to kelly let us know what's going
on in your heart and mind and we will
get you
on the show so um
here's the thing i a friend of mine sent
me an
article this morning and it's a
masterpiece and it's excellent it's by
erica greene
at new york times it's called the surge
of student
suicides pushes las vegas schools to
reopen
and if you go through it it really does
a great job of diving into
a n equals one the story of one
school district in las vegas that is
wrestling with
double the number of um child suicides
teen suicides
and these are is i mean we get there's
somebody in here as young as nine
nine and these kids have been at home
for a year they've been at home for a
year
and zoom school i know teachers are
doing whatever they can i know school
districts are coming up with all sorts
of
um ways that for students to connect
electronically
i know students are spending just hour
after hour in front of a zoom screen
and then they are going from that to
fortnite because that's the only way
they can connect with their friends
right now
and it's it's killing them it's
it's hurting kids and as i read through
this thing it's just
it's what every mental health
professional i know of
thought was going to happen down the
road back in march when we said man we
cannot shut kids off from each other
um they need connection and then here's
the thing kids aren't on there aren't
aren't special in this regard we all
need other people man and
i know this sounds somber i know i'm
usually trying to make jokes to start
the show off man but this thing's laying
heavy on me
because it's happening to adults too and
people are just getting crushed and so
here's the thing
i want to challenge every parent who's
out there um
to be hyper intentional i know you're
exhausted
i know this year has come with job loss
i know this year has come with
just maniacal political uncertainty i
know this
this year has come with so many
challenges i get that
um we're closing on half a million
people who've died
from covid i get it it is just been one
thing after another
i want you to do the best you can to
let anger leave your home i want you to
do the best you can
to connect with your kids and what does
that mean it means you got to figure out
ways to turn those screens off when that
zoom class is over
even if that means taking away video
games several days a week from your kids
even if that means you don't get to fall
down just in front of tv
dude i know the office reruns are
awesome i know shits creek's hilarious i
know all those shows are so good
and then they just keep putting great
show after great show after great i get
it i know i know i know
i know but
i don't know what else to say other than
we're at crisis mode here
our kids are desperate for us we are
desperate for
each other and um we've got to
reset our our our bearings from
collapsing at the end of the day to
really been able to look at our kids in
the eye and guys
that i'm talking about taking a soccer
ball to a park i'm talking about
um we had a fruit war in my living room
my kitchen the other day it spilled off
into the living room
where my son was working on some project
and i
literally just i hit him with a banana
and it kind of exploded and it made me
laugh and he drilled me with it and it
blew up all over me
and then we started throwing more food
at each other in our in our kitchen
my wife wasn't super impressed but i
think she could just see it we needed it
and it
turned into one of the hardest um
moments of laughter we've ever had
and um that's gonna be something that my
son's gonna tell at my funeral that time
that he pegged me with a banana
and hit me in the butt and it exploded
everywhere and um
so all i have to say is i don't care
what it is you got to do spray your kid
outside with a hose
go outside and build fort i don't care
what it is but guys we've got to do
something drastic
we've got to make some significant
changes and whatever it takes
we got to start looking at the data and
we got to figure out ways to get these
kids back in schools
and i'm not going to go down the
political trails here but we got to get
kids back in schools
we got to get kids around other kids
we've got to get kids around
buffering adults that teacher that gives
them a hug
that counselor that walks out putting
down the halls and just winks at your
kid
letting them know that they're okay man
man this thing's this thing's
heartbreaking i i hope everyone will go
to new york times
and dot com read this article again
it's uh yeah we'll put in the show notes
by erica green um
it's hard things are hard things are
hard and they need us to be grown-ups
they need us to be adults
and so um that's my public service
announcement for the day
good folks it is hard my hope is there's
a call for this stuff to start wrapping
up this summer i'm gonna tell you our
kids can't wait till this summer they
need to see other kids they need to see
each other and they need to see us and
whatever it takes for us let's do it
let's lean in
let's take the anger out of our homes
let's take the
turn the tvs off let's just get the
poison out of the house
and let's be about um loving our kids
let's be
about figuring out any way we can
connect connect connect
and that's it and um if your kid hits
you with a banana laugh because it's
pretty funny man
it's pretty funny all right let's go to
the phones let's go to brett in buffalo
new york brother brett how are we doing
man
i'm doing all right john how are you i'm
doing okay
um so how is buffalo these days y'all
doing all right
uh coming down with snow like crazy but
uh
we're doing all right good deal man so
how can i help you today uh so
uh my question was it was and i just
discovered this over the weekend is um
i did an ancestry dna test
and the result um that came back kind of
revealed
uh a 21 year old secret
um that i hadn't at all suspected
that my um the person that i thought was
my father
my biological father was not my
biological father
um and i confronted my um
mom with this news and uh
it was a very difficult conversation and
knowing that there had been i kind of
been lying to for 21 years
um so hey you weren't kind of lied to
brother you were absolutely lied to
yeah okay and i i just kind of
came i i found out that it's something
that other people
have a lot more people than i thought
had gone through but
um i the first thing i did when i
thought my life was spiral and now to
control is i
googled to see if this was something
that anybody had called about on your
show
and i didn't see it so i figured i'd
call that maybe and
maybe in you helping me there might be
other people out there that um
could also be helped by any advice that
you can give man brother you've got a
great heart and i appreciate your trust
and um appreciate you reaching out man i
i'm i'm
optimistic too that this call will help
a whole bunch of people who are dealing
with all kinds of secrets that they
didn't know about
um so is your dad still alive
um my dad actually passed away uh last
spring he had a degenerative
brain condition i'm so sorry and
i i gave the eulogy at his funeral
but we we had a tough relationship
because he he hadn't
been around since basically when i was
in middle school or so
um but i'd i kind of this year
you know there's there's a playbook for
dealing with loss i think and i i
thought i was kind of at peace
um you know bad things happen to people
um and i got to you know say my goodbyes
to him
it was um so i was kind of at peace with
it
um and then that was in april
um and then i found out um
just a few days ago um that he wasn't
my biological father after all so
tell me about this conversation with
your mom how did it go what did she have
to say about it
so our first conversation i think cause
it was so shocking to her that i found
out um
she it wasn't the first conversation
wasn't as good as the second and the
second wasn't as good as the third but
the first conversation
i just said hey mom
um is there i i just kind of said
i i think there's a secret you need to
tell me and
i i just want to know the truth and her
first
reaction in shock was
no you can't you can't stop stop you
can't talk about this you
i don't want you to ruin our family and
i said
i said i said mom you've already done
that for us not you
yeah i said mom you can't possibly be
the one who's angry in this situation
and then she kind of took a deep breath
and the conversation was better after
that point but the initial shock
it was kind of not great yeah
so was this just a one-time fling did
your dad did your
the person you thought was your dad and
i'm gonna call him your dad because
that's the role he played in your life
did he know about it um
to my knowledge he didn't have any any
uh clue about it wow and
so is this just a secret did your mom
have an affair with somebody or
um uh it was uh from what i found out it
was
an affair with a long time family friend
that i
that i know pretty well okay all right
so
here's here's the a couple of things to
think through moving forward number one
everything is gonna feel unmoored to you
you're gonna feel completely untethered
okay and i want you to rest in that
you're not
normal you're not crazy you're not
broken all right you should feel
like uh at the end of a flag waving in
the wind okay that's a normal feeling
um none of this at all um
none of this disrespects
discounts or loses the the father that
you knew
right that guy was acted as your dad
looks like he thought he was your dad he
he performed the roles of a dad
and i'm gonna call him my dad when i
talked about him too
absolutely honestly anybody can father a
child
very few people actually can step in and
be dads right this guy did
and so he didn't quote unquote father
you but he was your dad right
so honor that memory and love that um
at some point you're gonna have to come
to a resolution and
decide what you want to do about your
relationship with your mom
and what i will tell you is what she did
is unconscionable it's not right
and i don't want to be in the business
of judging what sort of social pressures
there were 25 how old are you
i'm only 21. okay 21 years ago should
she have told you absolutely man should
this have come to light and you'll have
these
conversations no question about that but
i don't want to go back
two decades or more and have revisionist
history on what was in her heart
and her mind and how safe she was and
all that stuff
right what i would rather do is spend
time living in the now and then moving
forward
and if you choose to not talk to your
mom you're welcome to do that if you
want to
if this is a relationship deal breaker
for you obviously it's a
massive fracture and trust right what
i'm going to
push you to do though is to forgive your
mom
okay not forgiving somebody only poisons
you
it doesn't it doesn't affect them at all
um
it it might have a psychological um you
know like a
low like a balm for them might feel good
but you're the one that's going to carry
around this hurt and this pain
and so at some point i want you to work
towards some sort of forgiveness with
your mom doesn't mean you have to
connect with her anymore i mean you have
to be
chums and buddies anymore i hope you all
can get there i hope you'll forgive her
um and going down the road but that's
not for today for today is you forgive
her so that you're not carrying those
bricks around and you can still
celebrate your dad
right and i i and after our first
conversation our
conversations were a lot more productive
and i
i do think i'm coming around and she was
remorseful and from my understanding is
that her not telling me and i i do
believe her
i think it was misguided but she she
thought she was protecting me from
information that would hurt me but um i
i can promise anyone out there if
they're keeping a secret it hurts a
whole lot more
to be lied to than any anything
that of this magnitude um
you know it hurts a lot more to be lied
to so i just implore anybody out there
who's keeping a secret too
that's right they're making that
calculation please just give
give your give your family the truth
secrets um destroy families from the
inside out that's for sure
so the question i want to know that
everyone listening is going to want to
know
are you going to give your dad a call
your your father a call
we've already we've already um we've
already
talked once um okay and it's weird
because i know other people in this
situation it's
a far-off distant person in whatever
town that someone met
20 years ago and for me it's not it's
somebody i
i actually know in the community so
here's if it hasn't already i want you
to expect this
i want you to expect the question to
rise up in the
base of your throat that will rattle in
your heart
and chest for probably the rest of your
life
which is why didn't you come
find me father right
how did you just sit there on the
sidelines for two decades
um that's going to come with all sorts
of grieving that's going to come with
anger it's going to come with
frustration and pain you're going to get
pissed off you're going to get mad he's
going to give you some
excuse and at the end of the day
you go running for your kid right i
don't just
passively let somebody else raise my
child and down the street from me
is that you know what i mean and so
you're gonna i agree you're gonna
wrestle with that
okay um i and it
it doesn't make it a whole lot better at
all i'll give you that
um and it's kind of one of those
hindsight this 20 20 things where
um when because my the person i knew as
my father was
mentally ill and um so our fine my
financial situation wasn't
great growing up for our family
and this person did
provide assistance but i that's not
enough and i
yeah no no i mean dude churches and
charity and the government gives us
money
our dads show up our dads give us the
most precious thing on planet earth that
they can never get back once they spend
it and that's their time
that's their that's their their touch
their eye contact right
and so yeah i mean we can high five them
for kicking and some money
he had to by law you're his kid right um
but he let somebody else raise you
and that's that's hard for me to even
hear on your behalf
um i can't even imagine what that's
going to be like
for you as you unpack that
again the easy thing for you to do is
going to be to go to war with
both of them and to say why didn't you
why didn't you why didn't you and you're
right to do that
that's fair but i'm going to tell you is
war only
ends up in piles of bodies it's not
going to solve that hole in your heart
it's not going to
give you any sort of answer that's going
to feel good
and what you need to do is moving
forward is decide what level of
relationship you want to have do you
want to get to know folks
you're in a unique situation where your
dad passed away
and i can imagine a scenario where this
is even more complicated and frustrating
um if you've got both of these men still
alive and
your dad finds out about this
that he was lied to for 20 years right
but the reality is he's passed away
we're not ever going to know what his
response would have been or anything
like that
what we do know is um
your mom seems to have loved you and man
she made it like you
i like your word she made a bad
calculation and she kept a secret that
poisoned her that poisoned your father
poisoned your home
and of course poisoned you and then you
got a guy down the street from you
that is your father and he chose to let
somebody else
raise you man that's hard
so yeah for anybody listening secrets
destroy
families man they just do they just do
and they create doubt and suspicion and
fear
and lack of trust in the hearts and
minds of children
don't do that to your kids brad i'm
sorry that happened to you man
i didn't you don't deserve that that
happened to you um
but all you can do is be a person of c
and character and integrity moving
forward
all you can do is choose to forgive and
not carry around
the sins and bricks of your parents
and not pass those along to your kids
all you can do is choose to continue to
do the next right thing
and that starts with forgiveness and
then starts to walk in a little lighter
load
i i will wish the best for moving
forward for the three of you
i hope you all come together and have
some sort of reconciliation in
relationship man we'll be thinking about
you
um you're doing it right you're starting
slow and you're starting with
conversations so good for you man
you are handling this probably more
mature than i would have at 21 that's
for sure
i appreciate your call and i appreciate
you caring for other people in the
country who find out i got a good friend
who just found out
i may have a brother or a half brother
that i didn't know existed that happens
um and what do you do when you go back
in time and
revisit why your parents made the
conversations and the
decisions they did why'd they choose to
do that why do you tell me
it was a different time 20 years ago 30
years ago 40 years ago it doesn't make
it right just makes it different
and so the most we can do is be graceful
and move on so
thanks again for that call brett oh boy
all right let's go to danielle
in jacksonville florida danielle how are
we doing
hey i'm good how are you i'm good i'm
good so what's going on in your world
so my 11 year old daughter was diagnosed
with add in second grade
we did try her we tried to run some
medication um she didn't do very well
with it it either made her
physically ill or just a totally
different depressed little girl she's
very happy
very you know like my little sunshine
girl i call her but so we're not doing
medication now
i've read gabor mates scattered minds
book
but i just need some tangible ways to
encourage her
to be more disciplined without her
feeling ashamed of herself
so give me a picture of like what was it
about her
in second grade that made you think uh
oh
something's wrong with my daughter i
need to get her medicated what like
paint me that picture what was going on
so she her teacher brought it up
to me and actually her stepmother too i
really just thought she was just
she she's very she's the life of the
party she's a social butterfly so i just
thought it was
just that's her personality i really
didn't think that she
had add but her stepmother said her
stepmother is a teacher
so she said i think she has this and
then her teacher
also said it um or that you know she's
having trouble focusing she can't
get her or she doesn't get her work done
her handwriting is really sloppy uh
she's just kind of scattered so
then i took her to the pediatrician and
they have this test i don't even know if
they still do it now but it was some fda
approved test to see if they had
adhd she's never been hyperactive um
but she but she did you know pat or you
know fail or whatever and they said that
she had add
so then we started the medication and it
just was it was not good
yeah so what do you see in your home
i i love your initial default which was
she's just a life of party this is her
personality we're gonna have some things
that
make her unique and beautiful in her own
way like
bonkers handwriting and man she's gonna
have to really stay on her
what what have you noticed that has made
you think my daughter's broken
okay so she um if she has
well when she does homework i usually
have to sit with her the entire time
or she you know she won't finish it she
just spaces out
she you know whatever if i tell her to
go do a task like today i told her
uh pick up the things off your floor and
i usually just try to give her one task
at a time
but it seems lately that even just the
one task
she gets distracted before she can get
it done okay so i said pick up the
things off the floor
and then empty your lunchbox and then go
clean your guinea pigs cage
so um she didn't even get to the first
one before she got distracted
how does she do with um how does she do
with lists
like if you sit down with her and say
all right let's make a list of the next
three things you've got to do
and you have a big check mark that would
have included those three things how
does she do with those
she does better with list but she'll do
the funnest thing
first whatever is the most fun that's
what's gonna you know
happen and then sometimes she forgets to
go back to the list even
okay so i have done that before and it's
it's like
you know she just sometimes doesn't go
back to the list yeah
so you mentioned um and again i'm gonna
ask these questions
not in a causal blame kind of way can we
promise me that you won't take them
there
sure i know it's so hard okay i'm trying
to get a full picture of your daughter
you mentioned she's got a stepmom and so
one of the
tenants of adhd that i just live by is
that it's not a brain disorder
but it's a developmental delay right and
often with their psychological tension
in the home
then that kids start to make sense of
their world
in a chaotic way um so she's from a home
of divorce is that right tell me about
the home she grew up in
so her father and i divorced when she
was two and a half i
think it was yeah two and a half um and
she
she in florida they want it to be kind
of 50 50. her dad lives
um on the other side of town so she
stays with me uh 60
of the time and then he gets them some
of the time her dad also has
ada too so um
so i mean we her dad and i didn't like
yell and argue and fight a lot it was
kind of
i guess like a deep like underlying
feeling of stress it was just kind of
it said it's that yeah kids absorb what
i call that low level tension that just
that it's that third rail that just
buzzes underneath the house at all times
yeah
right and children will absorb that and
then obviously the grieving process for
both of you after this is over
right and so here's a couple of
important things and i'll give you some
tangible things here
um super important please please please
let your daughter know she's not broken
and i would have a hard conversation
with stepmom and dad
we are not going to communicate to our
daughter that she's broke in any way
that she has some sort of
thing that is going to keep her from
having joy or being productive she's
going to need medication for the rest of
her life
i will tell you right now my childhood
was hard
and i wouldn't trade i'm off the chart
if you were to give me an adhd
test i'm off the chart on it and i
wouldn't trade
anything for it nothing um
because of the creativity the way i
solve problems all of that stuff
and i have to be highly intentional
about surrounding myself with a team of
people that keeps me accountable
just today on this show james was saying
before he started the show
you have one minute and i'm pushing
start on the record button right like
we're gonna do this right
and so um i do have a group of people
who will hold me accountable for being
on time which i struggle with because i
love just talking to people
being in relationship with folks i do
have folks that
that work with me on a task list and
this is stuff i've had to grow up and
learn how to do and it's hard and it's
challenging
but i wouldn't trade it for the world
okay and so i don't want your daughter
growing up thinking she's deficient
busted broken not like everybody else or
anything like that
your initial response that core thing
that came out of you which was
look at our unique daughter look what
she brings to the world
and to each social interaction she's
involved in that's a kind of spirit
and so what i tell parents often is this
is a context not an excuse
okay you have a you have a picture great
you still got to clean your room right
right so there's a balance between
going to war with a kid and coming up
with strategies that are going to help
them be
successful so what i've seen highly
successful in my own personal life
and with kids that i've worked closely
with
and with families is breaking tasks up
into bite-sized chunks especially for
young kids is a big deal
holding out the um like the fun one
you're gonna do these two and then the
fun one and then i'm gonna give you this
card and then we're gonna set the timer
and i'm gonna come check on you in ten
minutes
this is gonna be harder for you for the
next couple of years for both you
and your husband and stepmom right or if
your ex-husband and stepmom y'all gonna
have to lean in and so
with one of your kids you might be able
to say hey go clean your room and
they're gonna come back in 30 minutes
um i have found it helpful to walk into
a room and say all right
we're just doing shoes now when all the
shoes are up come back and find me
and they it may come back in three
minutes they're making 30 minutes
and i'm gonna go check on them so it's
breaking up
um jobs and bite size chunks and here's
what we're looking for we're looking for
little wins
we're looking for little successes to
build on not a
accumulative amount of failures to point
out does that make sense
okay um a a phrase that
guides my life is this don't forget to
remember
and i took that from dr mate but don't
forget to remember
and so often kids who are experiencing
this symptomology of adhd
they will walk through a room and they
won't see their clothes on the floor and
they won't
they just literally are are not
processing it right they're just running
right to the next thing
but you know what they know they know
feelings and they know how good it feels
when the room is clean
and so i will get out of my truck and
there'll be seven glasses in my truck
when i get home i don't know where they
come from they seem to grow
in my car uh but i will go start my
truck
in the winter and then i'll put a cup of
coffee in there and then i'll run
upstairs and
i need to get some coffee before i leave
the house and i'll come down with
another one i'll have two in there i'll
drink them both on the way to work
and then i'll come out of work and i'll
have to i don't know where they all come
from
but here here's the thing i remember how
good it feels when my truck is clean
when i get in the morning
and so every night i remember how good
it's gonna feel tomorrow and
for whatever reason that fuels me that
gets me to stop what i'm doing i know
how good it feels when i have that
little thing i put over my windshield
and it's not covered in ice right so
don't forget to remember so if you point
out feelings not failures for
a kid who's struggling in this way
remember how good it feels
when you do the fun thing remember how
good it feels when all of your clothes
are picked up
i want you just to get your dresses and
then come back and find me and just get
your tennis shoes and then come back and
find me and we're gonna celebrate those
little wins
and you mom are gonna get exhausted okay
you're gonna it's such a beating you
just wanna go do your thing right
and it's gonna be hard um the you're
teaching her
how to have little wins in her life and
these are gonna pay off big time down
the road
a couple of other things is exercise is
huge okay and we often think of
exercises burning off energy it's not
it's a
it's a way to get different chemicals
pulsing through the young
young body okay and it's good for her
it's good for you
and that could be walking and when y'all
go on walks together hold hands
make sure she's getting physical touch
from you and make sure that you have
skin to skin contact with her as much as
humanly possible make sure your husband
is doing that as well and i'm talking
about kind of obnoxious amounts
like i'm just gonna hold your face for a
second and this is super weird and i'm
your mom and i'm gonna be super weird
and you're gonna just have to get over
it
and she'll go mom this is so weird and
you'll be like i'm just a weird mom i'm
gonna hold your face
and you're gonna look at me in the eyes
you're going to count my um the little
creases in my in my eyes count my
wrinkles i dare you right
something like that but i want her to
start
consciously getting skin to skin contact
and
eye contact and then sleep is
major okay and sleep can be wartime for
kids that are struggling with this
but a sleep routine that no matter what
is going on ever
ever ever stick to that routine and
something about a kid's brain that has
sleep just slowly over time turns those
alarms off
okay schools i think are almost
borderline criminal for how early they
make kids get up
how early they um how much work they
give these kids in the evening time
and they've got kids going to bed at 10
o'clock and getting up at five o'clock
to be at school by 6 45
it's it's literally insane what we're
doing to these children's brains
and that may mean that you have to put
your start getting ready for bed at 7 30
and you're gonna feel weird um and then
have your kid in bed no later than eight
o'clock
7 30. we do real early bedtimes in our
house
um as you can imagine my kids they look
a lot like their dad
and sleep is everything a couple of
other things play with your kid
like play like hey let's you may have
heard me earlier talking about
do silly things like if you've got um
you know
go outside and play catch with a tennis
ball have water fights
but tangible things that they can touch
back to
i'm normal and i'm laughing and mom's
normal and she's laughing and we're all
doing stuff together
nature walking around outside barefoot
some of these things that are going to
sound really
weird and not like like kooky try them
out for 30 days
and i almost guarantee you that your kid
will
have a reorientation to you and to just
a more
peace right peace and if it's about
connection with your kid if it's about
playing with your kid if it's about joy
with your kid
and not about what they didn't do those
alarms in her heart and mine can start
to slow down and quiet a little
bit which then of course gives her an
opportunity to be a little bit more
successful with cleaning up
a little bit more successful with seeing
what how good that feels when she gets
something done
and so on and so on and so forth and
this
is going to be hard for you can i tell
you one more thing for you
please i want you to forgive yourself
and carry no
baggage about this in your own heart
okay
okay will you promise me that
yeah moms and dads absolutely beat
themselves up
for this parents who get divorced
absolutely beat themselves up for this
stuff
and what i'll tell you is that tension
that you feel
that shame that you feel that hurt
inside you that you feel
she absorbs that and she blames herself
for that feeling and tries to fix it
okay okay and so i want you just to be a
piece this is what it is your daughter's
beautiful sounds like she's fun she's
gonna be hilarious to me the life of the
party
she's gonna be an awesome person to be
employed by
and she's gonna have to have a really
killer admin assistant that keeps her on
track
right that's the way she's gonna that's
the way it's gonna work
and she is gonna have to learn some
skills that mom can't be calling her at
college saying did you do your homework
she's gonna have to learn how to fail
and she's gonna have to learn that mom's
not gonna pay for college when she fails
and so she's got to figure it out and
she will
right especially if you start these
connection
practices now i also want you to be
super graceful with her in this season
i don't know a single kid in the united
states of america that's not struggling
right now
covett has been a train wreck on these
poor kids and they've been locked in
front of screens they've had
weird associations even when they're at
school they're wearing masks it's just
been a mess
and so every signaling receptor system a
kid has which is
eye contact face contact watching
people's mouths laughing shoving each
other in the hallways all those things
all that's gone away overnight
and so if you have a kid who leans
towards being a little bit hyperactive
um if you have a a young girl who's
hyperactive which sometimes looks like
they shut down man this is just
messes with them it just melt melted
them so be graceful too
and i'll just tell you your daughter's
lucky to have you man i love
love love hearing from my mom hey i read
about it i'm learning about it what are
some tangible things so
do that for 30 days i'd love please
please please call me back danielle let
me know how this is going i'd love to
know how
um how your daughter's doing after 30
days of intense
intense sleep man movement
little little wins and a lot of contact
from mom
and mom forgiving herself and dropping
that brick of shame and
moving on and being joyful too that's
awesome all right let's take one more
call let's go to
uh laura in los angeles laura how are we
doing
i'm doing okay how you doing same i'm
doing same and i see you're from los
angeles and so i just automatically
stereotypically assume
things are extra hard for you guys right
now y'all doing okay
yeah i'm a nurse so so no you're not
doing okay you call my show and you're
and you're lying laura my gosh a nurse
in los angeles so tell me how we're
doing
i'm struggling yeah i definitely
um i'm feeling totally tapped out just
fried huh yeah
every tank and my tolerance level for
pretty much everything is that a zero
thank you very much
hey can i tell you stress manage
you earned it okay yeah i hate that for
you
um but you earned it full stripes right
yeah so for folks who who don't know
what it's like being a nurse the last
12 months give us a give us a some
insight
oh wow it is very very challenging
um especially the last couple of months
you know since thanksgiving it's just
been
and i'm not so swear on the radio but
you know it's been a show
yeah yeah and an age you can say what
you want to it's all good this is a
podcast man don't even count here
yeah i mean there's there's things that
can make your toes
curl when you hear about it and you see
these people
and it's her it's horrifying it's
genuinely horrifying and then in the
same day that you
have just coded a woman who is your
age and was chatting with you about her
kids
ten minutes earlier and the same day you
have a neighbor say to you is it really
that bad
i mean i didn't feel like it's that bad
it's so frustrating and
it's demoralizing it's depressing
it's disgusting all the ds except delony
[Laughter]
hey look at that hey you know what now
it's deloney too you've you've brought
me into this laura
thanks a lot um so
how are you how are you navigating this
i am struggling i am um
definitely normally a very mellow person
i i'm pretty quiet and i manage stress
in my own dysfunctional ways that don't
affect most people around me
what is that what is that oh eating okay
yeah and uh yeah just mostly eating
but lately i've just been zero tolerance
for
my kid my husband um people on the
freeway
you know it's la so that's pretty much
an everyday thing but it's worse now
um and then unfortunately i had a
patient the other day
who was very ungrateful and insulting
even and
it took everything i had not to just go
off on her and that's not me
i'm i feel really terrible for these
people and i
understand that she's upset because of
her situation not because of me and i'm
i'm not taking it personally but it's
hard to not internalize it
i'm sorry man hey i'm like for real i'm
sorry that you're doing this
that you're going through this um this
was all fun and good and everyone was
chanting nurses names the first three or
four months and i don't think anybody
expected this to still be going to full
tilt
a year later that's a long time to live
in the trauma of other people
and to live in the politicalization of
the hands you're holding every day right
right it's a nightmare right and then oh
by the way you're still a mom
too right and then every i don't know
once a month you got a husband that's
like so tonight tonight is the night and
you just want to stab him in the eye
with a fork right
oh laura um so what does
what does a full tank look like for you
what does
like take me back two years ago and what
i want what i want you to do
is is this number one i'm gonna tell you
things you already know this
right that being angry at somebody on
the highway
is just like that old um aaa saying
right you're just poisoning yourself
hoping somebody else is going to die and
they're not
right you know that um
and i also know that there's when our
brain processes are trying to protect us
and we stop
hearing the alarms they get louder and
louder and what your brain's trying to
tell you is hey we've had enough we got
to tap out for a minute
yeah and i don't know what that looks
like for you i don't know if you've got
a sabbatical
uh program or if you've got an ability
to walk into your boss hey i need a
minute like this is a lot and by a
minute i need like
two weeks but
nurses are warriors and you don't want
to leave your fellow nurses because you
know someone's gonna have to pick up the
slack
all that stuff so walk me through what
does it look like for you
i want to leave this call with a plan
for you is what i want to do because
there's a
bajillion people who are just like you
laura and you're such a gift
and whether they're nurses whatever it
is they're doing they are struggling and
they've had enough they can't do any
more
and then we're saying well maybe till
june and maybe until july and
maybe in the fall if people will chill
out and stop being dumb and and then we
you know it's just like i can't do any
more right
so let's get a plan together so tell me
what does it look like what is your when
your tank's full
um i don't even remember
i'm i'm a terrible patient you know like
i
i don't pay attention to myself i don't
take care of myself
so i don't really why not laura it's
been a very
very difficult few years actually
because my daughter was really sick when
she was a baby and then
my we almost lost our house in the fires
in 2018
and you know it just seems to be piling
one on top of the other and then with
covet it
it just feels like i don't know how to
find my way back to feeling that
sense of calm and so here's how i like
to
what you're experiencing is trauma all
over the place right
and you know that and we often think of
trauma as a gunshot or
a car wreck and you're experiencing it
with a sick kid
who may not make it you're experiencing
it with your house burning down your
neighborhood's on fire
literally you're experiencing it with
the political mess you're experiencing
it with
all the secondary traumatic stress of
being a nurse
and your body's telling you i've had
enough i gotta stop and the thing that
you know
that i know that we all know about our
bodies is um
if you won't stop it will stop you at
some point right
absolutely and it's showing it's showing
it's showing cracks
um all over the place so what does
processing this trauma look like what
does getting those bricks of a fire in
your backpack and
a sick kid and all of the marriage
stress that goes with this and not being
able to see your
friends and trying to solve everything
with
gummy candies that's what i do and with
bourbon and what like how do you what do
you do to get those bricks out of your
backpack
because here's the thing you have to
start taking care of yourself or i'm
going to call you out and tell you that
you don't love your patients like you
say you do
because you can't take care of them
unless you're okay
you got to put your oxygen mask on first
so what does that look like
i guess i probably need to um
enforce taking more time
for myself you know not
not spending the time that i do have to
think about
things to worry i spend a lot of time
worrying
about stuff and yeah but that worries
just part of your alarm system
right and that sucker spun out what does
it look like to
what shift do you work on day shift okay
so what does it look like to get off of
work and
to sit down with your husband and say
hey i need some help around the house
um i'm i'm kind of cracking and he's
gonna smile and say yeah
we we know and my husband is wonderful
he cleans more than i do oh that's
awesome
so you've got to do it again you've got
a great i have a very good support
system partner
awesome so what does it look like um
well how about this i won't put you on
the spot anymore i'll give you some
some ideas okay please i'll give you
some ideas
number one i'm gonna i'm gonna call you
out i'm gonna call it everyone listening
to this
if you don't take care of yourself you
are saying i do not care about those who
love me
and that's a mean way to say that but
i'm just i've got to start being more
upfront to people
who are working in the hard lives of
other people and i've got to say that to
myself
if i choose to not take care of myself i
am choosing to be less of a good dad
and choosing to be less of a good
husband and a good connected community
member
i've got to put some of my wellness and
health needs first otherwise people
around me are not going to get
my best self and so what does that mean
that means on certain days um when my
alarm goes off
my wife's hand will slide under the
covers that not where you think laura
she will just grab my hand and we will
sit there and hold hands for the first
four or five minutes that we both wake
up
and occasionally we'll just touch feet
this isn't a sexual thing this is
just skin to skin contact okay yeah
and there's there's all kinds of
physiological and biochemical research
that comes with that but it just is a
grounding
it lets your body know i'm tethered and
i'm okay you are also blessed you got an
awesome old man that lives a
husband that just loves you loves you
right and so that's the best
the second thing is is you're not gonna
like this and i don't like it either
this is me the pot talking in the kettle
here
we've got to take care of our nutrition
we have to we've got to fuel our bodies
in the right way
and that may mean two or three weeks of
just utter hell getting off of sugar and
getting out of some of the
the cyclical nonsense of more grains
more sugar more grains more sugar ah
crash whatever
um and that may mean a fun adventure of
sitting on your husband saying hey we
gotta we gotta wrap some stuff up
because i'm coming
i can't keep putting water in the gas
tank right
the next thing is you gotta get off of
work and
especially you get off at seven you're
gonna have to be
militant about staying away from screens
and you're gonna be militant about
doing active things and that's hard
after you've been on your feet all day
but it might just be simple like taking
a walk with him saying hey will you make
me take a walk and hold my hand while we
walk
and if you can get away with it walk
around
in the grass and walk with no shoes on
and there's something about the
grounding effect of
being still and being present that being
barefoot and holding somebody's hand
does for you
the other thing is is where you can i
know this is exhausting again you're
lucky you got a guy that's stepping in
is half people over to your house or go
places where you can i don't even know
what the rules are where you are
but you've got to get with community and
not talk about nursing stuff and not
talk about coding people
and not talk about death and not talk
about sickness and not talk about
politics
but just talk about life just talk about
laughter just talk about
whatever but learn
to practice to be a person again and
this is again the pot talking to the
kettle man
because people who work in trauma they
all hang out with people who work in
drama because that's we're the only ones
exactly what i was going to say is i
don't really know anybody
i know so laura you
have to and it's going to be awkward and
weird listen when i moved to nashville
i knew the science i knew the data and
it was super weird
you know what i did i had a couple of
two couples at my house
and my wife me and my wife had them
there at our kitchen table
and i said this is gonna be weird but
we would like to ask you to be our our
friends
there was an awkward silence and it was
like hey here's what this means we're
going to show up and
when you need something at 2 a.m we're
going to show up and we may call you
and we'd love to have you involved in
our kids life and it ended up being
a awkward messy beautiful conversation
because here's what i know
my tendency is to retreat and only hang
out with people who do graphic
gross things for a living and i know the
science tells me that trauma is
cumulative
and so when i get home and i play
fortnight or i get home and i watch
some awesome netflix show that is just
uh
about serial killers and murderers and
then i get the podcast
another serial killer podcast when i'm
working out all that is just trauma on
top of trauma on top of trial on top of
trauma dude and my brain can't take it
anymore
right yes absolutely and then the only
thing that feels better
makes things go away is pizza and the
whole two liter coke and then the only
thing the next morning that feels better
is starting the whole stupid cycle over
again
right yeah yeah and so start
i just would love to be at your house
and you have this conversation tonight
you're going to tell your husband
starting tomorrow morning when the alarm
goes off
i want you to reach under the covers and
hold my hand pervy hold my hand
and then i want you to slide your leg
over and i'll just touch our bare feet
and we're going to lay there for five
minutes
you can say some wackadoo on the radio
said to do this
and then tell him you're responsible for
making me an awesome breakfast
and it's got to be something with high
fat and high protein that's healthy for
me that's not just going to make my
blood sugar crash at 10
and make me hit the vending machines and
i want you to text each other throughout
the day and check in with one another
if you got friends you can text funny
silly things too awesome
hug hug hug hug that little one when you
get home
go for a walk don't just plop down want
you to go for a walk barefoot if you can
hold hands if you can
here's the final thing either in the
morning or in the evening i think for
you in the evening it's going to be
better
so once you start keeping a gratitude
journal start every day i mean end every
day with five things i am grateful for
you can name patients you can maybe get
a pseudonym in your book just to be
hypocrite but
you can name patients you can name a
doctor that helped a fellow nurse you
can name your kid you can name your
husband you could name
whatever you want to but just begin to
orient yourself
away from all i see is people dying
all i see is people trying to politicize
hurt all i see
is people trying to tell me that i'm
crazy all i see
is a sweet mom that i'm talking to about
her kids and then she just passes away
on me right in front of me
and all i see that it over and over i
want you to begin to orient yourself
towards looking for beauty
looking for joy looking for the good
because there is good we just have to go
find it during the season
and i'll end it with this if you know a
nurse if you know
a man somebody in the healthcare
professions right now
i'm just calling on everybody to get
this go do something nice for them today
call them pay for a meal
go over to their house and sit on the
front porch bring coffee i don't care
what you bring
show up and be in the lives of people
who are in the nursing profession nurse
practitioners people who work in
hospitals they
are just out of gas and this thing's not
stopping
that we've got to have them whole and
that starts with us being good community
members and reaching out so
laura thank you so so much i want you to
try that give me a month
right so give me a month and circle back
and let me know how it goes
and you can say like hey i did all that
stuff and i still hate my life and
you're an idiot deloney and i
i'll play that on the radio that would
be that'll be fun but it's not going to
happen that way all right so as we wrap
up today's show
man i went to a concert a few years ago
at the ryman auditorium
i went to see a band that i loved from
back in the day and
there was an opening band there and it's
only happened one other time
where the opening band just you know two
other times in my life
but the opening band just walks away
with the show
to by the end of the openers act
everyone is standing up
on all feet on their feet yelling
singing along and it was just a sense of
joy and compassion
and beauty that i've really ever seen in
a live performance
their their records are just astounding
and this is one my favorite song of
theirs one of the best songs
ever written ever it's from a beautiful
wonderful
married couple who are veterans called
war and treaty
and the song is off the album the
healing tide the song itself is called
the healing tide
out in 2018 and it goes like this
what if i told you you would be the one
to bring world peace
what if i told you a willing heart and
soul is what you need
what if i showed you how to make a good
out of something wrong what if i
wrote you a song from the heart of your
world would you let me be your boy
would you be a part of the healing tide
a part of the healing tide what if i
told you
you'd be better off the second time
around what if i told you that not
all goes up will come down what if i
told you how to take
the bad and make something good what if
i gave you my heart from the state of
your world
would you be a part of the healing tide
war and treaty check them out this has
been the dr john dalon chef
[Music]